[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Patrick canner bonjour merci d'être avec
nous monsieur canner sénateur du Nord
président du groupe socialiste au Sénat
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse régionale représenté par
Christelle Bertrand du G plat despêch
bonjour Christ bonjour bonjour patri
bonjour à vous on va parler de
l'information de cette nuit du côté
d'Israël et cette frappe qui a touché un
hôpital de Gaza faisant des centaines de
morts est-ce qu'il faut craindre une
escalade et un embrasementvez l'escalade
elle a déjà commencé dès le 7
octobre Israël n'a rien demandé les
citoyens israéliens ont été massacrés
violés brûlés brûlés c'est ah quand on
est juif ça signifie quelque chose par
rapport à la Choa et au four
crématoire donc le Hamas a une charte
euh qui dit clairement que la Palestine
a été jurpée par les Juifs et qu'il faut
lancer le djihad donc ça veut dire
massacrer les juifs ou les jeter à la
mer donc l'escalade a commencé le 7
octobre Israël est un État de droit qui
a le droit de se défendre dans le
respect des règles internationales et
pour revenir à votre question sur
l'embrasement et ce qui s'est passé de
terrible hier j'ai vu ces images comme
nous tous ce matin cet hôpital qui a
explosé littéralement
euh bien sûr C accuse Israël Israël
répond c'est un missile du Djihad
islamique qui a été mal lancé je pense
qu'il faut que toute la clarté soit
faite et qu'une enquête internationale
totalement indépendante puisse
déterminer quelles sont les
responsabilités réelles en la matière il
y a eu des manifestations dans plusieurs
pays cette nuit et notamment il y en a
eu devant l'ambassade de France en
Tunisie avec des slogans auosyle à la
France hostile à Emmanuel Macron allié
des sionistes c'est ce que disaient les
manifestants qu'est-ce que vous dites de
ça c'est vraiment absolument terrible ça
montre que en fait le conflit
israelllo-palestinien qui date depuis
trop longtemps il
faudrait relancer les accords d'Oslo
trouver la solution à deux états n nous
le savons mais ce conflit
israël-palestinien est un prétexte
finalement au lancement d'une d'un refus
finalement de ce que nous représentons
vous savez la Tunisie aujourd'hui est un
pays qui pose des problèmes sur le plan
démocratique nous nous le savons bien et
et tous les mouvements islamistes euh le
ramas daesh le Jihad islamique et bien
d'autres euh ont une haine féroce de ce
que nous représentons collectivement je
le disait à Madame borne la semaine
dernière au moment des questions
d'actualité il y a exactement une
semaine euh nous sommes un cauchemar
pour les islamistes euh la liberté
d'expression la démocratie le droit des
femmes à disposer de de leur corps la
laïcité c'est un cauchemar et nous
sommes face à une attaque en règle
vis-à-vis euh de ce que nous sommes à
savoir le les enfants les dignes enfants
de la lumière et du siècle des Lumières
donc attention danger euh ce qui s'est
passé avec Dominique Bernard j'ai une
pensée particulière pour lui-même et sa
famille ce qui s'est passé il y a 48 he
avec l'assassinat de deux touriste
suédois
euh par un terroriste aussi dit le loup
solitaire montre que euh ce qu'on
appelle le djihadisme d'atmosphère
maintenant est en train de se développer
euh et que manifestement des loups
solitaires ce que Bernard casenu
appelait quand il était au gouvernement
un un djihadisme lowcost du terrorisme
Holocaust estre en train de se
développer il faut vraiment être
extrêmement donc moins détectable
puisque c'est des gens qui se
radicalisent en solitaire et et qui
utilise des couteaux c'est-à-dire des
armes qui ne sont qui ne sont pas
interdites est-ce que du coup ça ça ça
ça doir repenser aussi la façon de
lutter contre ce
dihadmeist le risque zéro n'existe pas
mais il nous faut des services de
renseignement efficaces il nous faut des
politiques de prévention efficace il
faut que l'éducation soit le remède
total finalement vis-à-vis de ces
développements que nous devons combattre
parce que encore une fois c'est notre
modèle de société qui est attaqué et le
conflit israëlo-palestinien par lequel
nous avons commencé ce matin je ne dis
pas n'est pas qu'un prétexte mais ce
n'est qu'un élément euh d'une volonté de
déstabilisation de notre société on va
en parler avec chist alors Bruno
rotaillot et Hervé Marseille souhaitaent
que soit mise à l'ordre du jour du Sénat
ce soir une résolution pour condamner
les crimes du Hamas et soutenir les
Israéliens le gouvernement a refusé de
le mettre à l'ordre du jour est-ce que
vous le regrettez le gouvernement
manifestement a prévu de déclencher ce
qu'on appelle un article 50-1 de la
Constitution c'est-à-dire un débat qu'il
va initier à l'Assemblée et au Sénat
nous verrons dans quel ordre permettant
à à chaque groupe politique de pouvoir
s'exprimer sur le sujet et a priori je
serai le représentant du groupe
socialiste si ce débat est confirméord
donc ça peut remplacer cette résolution
ce n'est pas le même sens une résolution
elle est
votée par la chambre dans laquelle cela
se passe
euh je ne suis pas certain que le
gouvernement veuille un vote sur
pourquoi par craint de pas avoir la
majorité sur ce sujet-l je n'en sais
rien nen sais rien
mais est-ce que vous regrettez que ce
débat n'est pas lieu ce soir comme le
souhaitaent plusieurs sénateurs ah le
gouvernement est maître de l'ordre du
jour parce que c'est une gouvernementale
hier Bruno rotaillot à votre place il
disait c'est un mépris du Parlement oui
mais ça c'est un mépris généralisé le
fait qu'on refuse au Parlement
d'inscrire en tout cas la majorité
sénatoriale d'inscrire un texte montre
bien qu'il y a là une forme de
hiérarchie entre l'exécutif et le
Parlement c'est il y a bien d'autres
exemples qui ont qui peuvent être
utilisés du 493 ou 42 de bon peu importe
et sur le fond est-ce que vous dites
finalement c'est mieux qu'il y ait pas
de vote ou est-ce qu'il aurait fallu un
vote ah moi je ne craignais pas le vote
je ne suis pas certain que nous auurons
signé le texte présenté par Monsieur
rotaillot et Monsieur Marseille parce
qu'il y avait des choses qui pouvaient
être pour nous des irritants
permettez-moi l'expression mais sur le
fond il fallait dénoncer al vous savez
sur notamment l'aide
humanitaire qui aurait pu être
conditionné on ne conditionne pas une
aide humanitaire les civils doivent être
aidés dans toutes les HP donc il y avait
des choses à faire évoluer le texte
n'est pas inscrit à l'ordre du jour nous
aurons le débat sur le 50-1 chacun
pourra s'exprimer mais le gouvernement
je ne sais pas si c'est le mot de mépris
le plus adapté mais le gouvernement nous
considère comme des supplétifs de sa
politique et bien non le Parlement ne
peut pas être un suppletif de la
politique gouvernementale alors cette
question d'Israël elle fracture la nuup
on va longuement en parler hier Daniel
auono député la France insoumise a redit
que le Hamas n'était pas une
organisation terroriste mais un
mouvement de résistance qu'est-ce que
vous avez ressenti en entendant ça à
vomir à vomir moi je l'ai découvert
d'abord par un tweet et puis après j'ai
écouté exactement ce que ce que madame
obono a dit je suis scandalisé
d'ailleurs il semblerait que même à
l'intérieur du groupe LFI il y a eu des
remarques désobligeantes à son écart
mais madameono c'est pas la première du
genre je dire elle a participé en
novembre 2019 à la marche du CCIF elle a
invité dans sa campagne à Paris monsieur
Jérémy Corbin ancien leader travail qui
a été évincé pour voilà des des
complicités d'antisémitisme il y a une
forme d'antisémitisme chez une partie
d'alafi je ne vais pas jusque là je dis
simplement que les frontières on le sait
bien entre antissionisme et
antisémitisme sont parfois ténu est ce
qui est certain c'est que la volonté de
Madame auonau ou de Monsieur Mélenchon
ou de Monsieur bpard d'essentialiser les
habitants des quartiers populaires en le
disant mais vous êtes d'abord des
musulmans peut-être avant même d'être
des Français je vais un peu loin
peut-être mais c'est quand même cela qui
est en jeu c'est-à-dire une un débat
électoraliste et une volonté finalement
de considérer que cette France coloniale
doit être combatue il y a des vieux
ressorts qui reviennent en la matière
madame bobono fait partie de cette
extrême gauche que j'ai toujours
combattu dans ma vie politique qui est
aujourd'hui député grâce à un accord qui
s'appelle l'anupe on va en parler
certainement et qui mérite d'être
totalement revisité donc je condamne
fermement les propos de cette collègue
parlementair et je ne sais pas s'il faut
aller jusqu'à une démarche judiciaire
qui a
été
princi il a eu raison ou pas en tout cas
il faut faire le le lien entre les
propos de Madame auonau et effectivement
un appel peut-être à la haine qui est
condamnable dans notre pay vous dites
pas apologie du
terrorisme gérmanin il a saisi pour
apologie du terrorisme oui c'est la
dimension de Monsieur Darmanin ce qui
est certain que Darmanin aujourd'hui une
priorité c'est de protéger la population
juive de ce pays les Français de
confession juives et les propos de
Madame obono peuvent créer des
mouvements partout dans y compris dans
les quartiers antisémites et ça c'est
très grave Elisabeth borne hier soir a
dit que LFI n'était plus dans l'arc
républicain après ses propos pour vous
c'est le cas ou c'est simplement un
problème Daniel auonau Jean-Luc
Mélenchon manuel Bompard non c'est c'est
ce n'est pas qu'un problème de
gouvernance et de fonctionnement de de
LFI Monsieur Mélenchon est dans une
logique persécutionnelle permanente il a
envie d'exister y compris en disant mais
tout le monde m'en veut euh dit que ces
propos engagent totalement
LFI tant que LFI n'aura pas condamné les
propos de son patron permettez-moi
l'expression parce que il s'est dit en
retrait depuis 1 an et on n on na jamais
vu autant y compris sur les médias donc
le vrai patron de LFI c'est Jean-Luc
Mélenchon avec ses alliés Monsieur
bonpard Madame panneau à l'Assemblée
nationale madame Bomono et d'autres mais
je sens bien que chez d'autres membres
de LFI Ruffin Corbière Clémentine otin
il y a plus qu'une interrogation et donc
etfi doiTent faire son elle a parlé de
faute Clémentine Autin elle a dit c'est
une faute oui c'est une faute et et on
voit bien que cette provocation
permanente de Monsieur Mélenchon
aujourd'hui est une atteinte finalement
à la logique du de la gauche qui avait
régné en 2022 la vraie question qui nous
est posée aujourd'hui nous sommes
socialistes c'est est-ce qu'on on peut
continuer à travailler avec un mouvement
politique qui n'est pas un mouvement
démocratique je tiens à insister nous
avons signé avec LFI qui n'a aucune vie
démocratique pour vousf c'est pas un
mouvement démocratique ah ben pas du
tout pas du tout Monsieur Mélenchon il a
été élu parti parce qu' y a pas
d'élection interne il pas d'élection
interne il n'y a pas de sensibilité qui
peuvent s'exprimer sinon c'est un crime
de laise Majesté si elle s'exprime donc
non LFI est un mouvement politique qui a
marqué les esprits et notamment une
élection en particulier mais qui a des
élus pardon mais qui a des élus qui a
des élus nationaux 75 députés je le ni
pas mais vous avez vu les élections
sénatoriales est-ce que vous avez vu un
sénateur et les filles élu la réponse
est non donc il n'y a pas que la
légitimité liée à l'élection
présidentielle je dis souvent il y a une
vie avant les présidentielles il y aura
une vie après les présidentielles
Monsieur Mélenchon a voulu faire de
l'élection présidentielle l'ALPA et
l'oméga de tout qu'on soit clair Patrick
hanner pour vous il y a pas un problème
de Mélenchon comme le dit il un problème
donc ça va au-delà de jeanluc mélchon il
y a un problème idéologique quand
Monsieur Mélenchon participe à la
manifestation du CCIF en novembre 2019
quand il dit la police tu quand il dit
au début de la guerre Russ
Russie-Ukraine quand il dit mais est-ce
qu'il faut vraiment livrer des armes à
l'Ukraine qui n'importe comment ne
pourra rien faire avec ses armes face à
la Russie quand il ne dénonce pas comme
il le faut les émeutes urbaines et quand
il ne dit pas que le Hamas est un
mouvement terroriste excusez-moi oui il
y a un problème politique voire même
idéologique majeur avec Monsieur
Mélenchon mais Mélenchon n'est que le
haut de l'iceberg il y a autre chose
derrière lui est-ce que les filles
capable voilà de d'en prendre toute la
considération et de dire ça suffit et
bien c'est au militants aux adhérentss
entre guillemets de LFI d'en faire la
démonstration hier soir le conseil
national du Parti socialiste a voté un
moratoire suspendant sa participation à
la nuupass est-ce que c'est suffisant
pour vous ou est-ce qu'il aurait fallu
plus loin moi je j'ai soutenu la
démarche initiée par les Amis de Nicolas
meyerignol et d'ÉEN Geoffroy visant à
une suspension claire et nette avec
elle fille en terme de négociation et en
terme de de contribution au travail et
quelle est la différence parce que là
vous avez acté supens moratoire tout
d'abord c'est un terme qui n'est pas
clair excusez-moi on pourra avoir
beaucoup de sens sur le mot moratoire et
quand on dit suspension ça veut dire
qu'on arrête on arrête donc vous vous
étiez pour la rupture déf tive la
rupture est quelque chose qui se
constate après une période de je dirais
de de réflexion là vous vous suspondz
votre participation à l'intergroupe
qu'est-ce que vous pouriiez faire de
plus de votre point de vue moi je pense
que c'est de remettre tout à plat et de
dire à un moment donné avecfi est-ce
qu'on peut continuer à travailler
ensemble là il y a des réunions qui vont
être organisées pour discuter de ça
justement à l'initiative de des
écologistes les écologistes et le PC ont
une position différente de celle qui a
été exprimé on va parler mais juste
comment ça s'est passé Conseil national
pour le coup chez vous il y a du débat é
il y a eu il y a eu du débat il y a eu
du débat moi je regrette que la
direction nationale euh qui a proposé un
texte avec le mot moratoire n'est pas
accepté que un autre texte que nous
avons porté soit soumis aussi au vote
vote qui a eu lieu hier vers 1h du matin
je tiens à le préciser euh donc les nu
ont été courtes euh gagé à 54 % et 54 %
et 46 % donc c'est ça montre que mais
vous l'avez voté ou pas vous le ce
moratoire moi je n'ai pas le droit de
vote mais je n'aurais pas voté votre
ligne je suis membre de droit en tant
que président du groupe mais si j'avais
eu le droit de vote j'aurais voté contre
le texte de la direction nationale parce
que j'estime qu'il ne va pas assez loin
et
qu'il pour moi il ne constitue pas un
acte suffisamment fort pour dire à LFI
ça suffit Monsieur Mélenchon ça suffit
il faut vraiment tout remettre à plat et
reconstruire une autre union je
considère que la nuèche qui a été un
accord électoral qui est devenu
prressivement un outil au service de
Monsieur Mélenchon pour ses ambitions
gouvernementales et on sait que ses
ambitions et bien sont quand même
limitées parce qu'il est dans la
protestation et dans la logique du Grand
Soir et bien cette nupess aujourd'hui
pour moi est une impasse politique il
faut recréer une autre union de Al
quelle autre union que aujourd'hui vous
pourriez recréer vous savez moi je suis
un enfant la gauche politiquement
l'union de la gauche avec le PC avec les
Radicaux de Gauche a existé aujourd'hui
avec les vers je pense que LFI tel
qu'aujourd'hui piloté managé par
Monsieur Mélenchon ne peut plus faire
partie selon moi de l'union de la gauche
tel que je l'imagine c'estd la
gauch une partie de LFI c'est à LFI d'en
décider et pour être très clair c'est à
ceux qui contestent la ligne politique
idéologique de Monsieur Mélenchon et
bien de prendre leur responsabilité une
union qui pourrait intégrer Bernard
casenf par exemple et son mouvement
Bernard casneuve qui vient de s'exprimer
sur une chaîne concurrente a confirmé il
était favorable de la gauche mais il
considère que LFI aujourd'hui est un
élément qui ne peut pas moralement être
considéré comme app partenaire naturel
de l'union de la gauche et je crois
qu'il a raison au travers des différents
exemples que j'ai pu vous donner jusqu'à
présent donc LFI a été créé par Jean-Luc
Mélenchon pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et pour les ambitions
personnelles de Jean-Luc Mélenchon donc
je considère que aujourd'hui il s'est
discrédité clairement et pas que depuis
l'affaire du ramas terroriste il s'est
discréqué depuis de nombreux mois voir
même de nombreuses années dans ce pays
le score de 22
% est bien sûr une réalité politique
mais très ponctuelle et on le voit bien
etfi est un colosse au pied d'argile qui
n'a pas d'implantation territoriale et
nous nous devons négocier avec ceux avec
qui nous pouvons construire un avenir
pour la GAE la question qui a mise en
avant Olivier fort à de nombreuses
reprises depuis un an c'est la question
de l'Incarnation et dit sans Jean-Luc
Mélenchon on est peu audible est-ce que
vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui cette gauche
sans Jean-Luc Mélenchon pourrait être
audible sachant qu'il y a pas un leader
évident pour l'incarné si la gauche est
audible parce que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
parle dans les conditions que je viens
de vous évoquer et bien j'ai beaucoup de
tristess moi je souhaite que la gauche
retrouve d'abord une ligne politique de
responsabilité que l'incarnation viendra
ensuite vous savez pour gagner il faut
d'abord une ligne politique il faut une
stratégie électorale et il faut une
incarnation il faut les trois je vous le
concède aujourd'hui l'incarnation n'est
pas déterminée en tout cas ce ne sera
jamais pour Mo jeanluc Mélenchon rest
est déterminé non la et le PS a un rôle
particulier en la matière à imaginer il
faut que nous reconstruisions cette axe
centrale pour la gauche celle de la
responsabilité il faut que nous ayons
une stratégie électorale claire avec nos
partenaires et pour être très direct
avec le Parti communiste avec les vers
avec les radicau de gauche et peut-être
une partie de LFI vous
l'avez évoqué il y a quelques instants
et il faudra une incarnation mais
l'incarnation c'est c'est la fin d'un
processus mais il faut aller vite par
rapport à hier soir vous êtes divisé sur
cette question de l'Incarnation
justement lors du Conseil national
certains voulaient faire voter un texte
qui a été voté disons qu'il y aura un
candidat unique en 2027 en 27 vous
n'étiez pas tous favorables à ça je moi
je considère que le candidat unique en
2027 c'est peut-être l'assurance d'être
présent au second
tour mais c'est l'assurance d'être battu
au second tour parce qu'il n aura plus
aucune unee réserve de voix il faut
permettre à nos concitoyens de choisir
au premier tour c'est une élection
scrutin majoritaire à deux tours et de
se rassembler au second tour
contand candidat unique c'est ça mais
question écoutez l'histoire l'a montré
Françis mitteran n'était pas le candidat
unique de la gauche François Holland n'a
jamais ét c'était pas la même force à
l'époque de françoisterran et vous avez
fait moins de 2 % pour que je vous dis
qu'il faut repartir du PS pour espérer
être présent contour avec un candidat
crédible imaginez-vous un mon tour
Jean-Luc Mélenchon en 2027 Madame Le Pen
je suis prêt à vous signer déjà le
résultat le penidemment et très
largement et très largement donc est-ce
qu'on veut cela est-ce qu'on monsieur
manchon a envie peut-être que mêême Le
Pen soit élu pour créer les conditions
d'une révolution dans ce pays et que les
masses populaires se mobilisent dans le
cadre d'un grand
spart maisne parce que il faut arrêter
avec cette ce fantasme de l'extrême
gauche que représente Monsieur Jean en
interne vous nous dites hier il y a eu
des débats il y a eu des divisions il y
a eu le refus d'un vote sur un texte qui
était autre est-ce qu'Olivier fort est
assez ferme pour vous Olivier fort n'a
pas changé de stratégie euh un peu quand
même puisque là il a le moratoire je
pense que colivier fort et et ses
proches ce que je ne suis pas vous le
savez puisque il ne souhaitait pas que
je soit un nouveau président du groupe
socialiste au Sénat mais voilà il
pensait peut-être qu'il y avait une une
reconduction du congrès de Marseille au
groupe du Sénat ça n'a pas marché votre
élection c'est la défaite d'Olivier fort
pour vous en tout cas c'est la défette
du candidat d'Olivier fort éricou et
donc à travers é rouge d'Olivier fort ah
bah Olivier fort s'est engagé
personnellement dans cette campagne au
sein du groupe socialiste euh voilà je
ne pensais pas que ça irait jusque là
mais ça a été le cas mais vous savez je
ne suis pas rancugier non vous êtes moi
mon objectif vous savez c'est c'est que
le groupe de socialiste travaille qu'il
soit puissant qu'il soit connu reconnu
et qu'il soit uni et est-ce que vous
vous êtes Unis justement là-dessus au
sein du groupe socialiste bah écoutez le
groupe socialiste il est partagé comme
le Parti socialiste je dis simplement et
pour répondre à votre question initiale
Olivier fort pense que la nupes est un
bon vecteur pour reprendre le pouvoir
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui la nupè est
devenu un boulet pour la gauche que le
mot nupè est détesté par une partie de
la gauche et pas que par une partie de
la gauche par une partie des Français
vous savez je sors d'une élection
sénatoriale combien de maires dans le
Nord mont dit mais Patrick tu es pas
nups hein tu as pas de LFI sur ta liste
euh ça veut dire que le PS s'abîme en
restant avec LFI je dis que le PS doit
retrouver sa force centrale et je ne
suis pas sûr que ce soir en étant euh
dans la suite de lfic que cela pour
estceil y a aujourd'hui un travail
commun entre socialistes écologistes
communistes pour créer une STR la
structure commune dont vous parliez tout
à l'heure est-ce qu'il y a des
rencontres encore pas encore pas encore
mais je je le souhaite vous savez
reprenons l'exemple du Sénat nous
n'avons pas de nup au Sénat qu'il n'y a
pas
d'intergroupe moi je considère très
simplement que ce que nous avons montré
au Sénat notamment sur le débat sur les
retraites avec les Verts avec les
communistes que nous sommes capables de
parler et j'aimerais que nous puissions
construire un programme de gouvernement
commun programme commun ça rappellera
des souvenirs à certains mais cette l
construction est nécessaire nous sommes
en
2023 il nous reste un an pour bâtir
finalement une nouvelle union à laquelle
j'aspire Christelle un mot sur la loi
immigration un mot sur la loi
immigration le projet doi qui est arrivé
qui arrive pardon le 6 novembre prochain
au Sénat aurait pu éviter le drame
d'aras a dit Gérald armanin est-ce que
vous le pensez est-ce que le
gouvernement a eu tort de tergiverser
sur ce texte là qui attend depuis
quasiment un an je je n'ai pas de boule
de cristal je ne sais pas si ce loup
solitaire qui a qui a tué Dominique
Bernard aurait pu être évité moi je je
crois à la force de notre police à la
force de no servicees de de
renseignement c'est ça qui non mais
est-ce que dans le contexte actuel vous
dites il faut un texte immigration il
faut qu'on prenne des mesures en tout
cas ce texte arrive le 6 novembre moi je
est-ce que vous réfléchissez à le voter
du coup il y a la partie sur la
régularisation et le mot ne fait pas
plaisir à tout le monde nous y sommes
favorables nous considérons qu'il faut
donner un statut à celles et ceux qui
font vivre l'économie dans ce pays elle
est fragilisée aujourd'hui cette partie
justement cette partie est fragilisée
notamment par qui n'en veut pas le Fame
article 3 et donc si l'article 3 est
supprimé
dans je ne voterai pas le texte nous ne
voterons pas même passe par une
circulaire pour vous c'est pas un
compromis acceptable écoutez je je
considère aujourd'hui qu'il faut aller
jusqu'au bout de cette
démarche presque fraternelle de dire à
quelqu'un qui bosse dans le pays qui ne
pose aucun problème qui n'a qu'envie que
d'être voilà intégré dans le pays il
faut lui permettre de le faire est-ce
que c'est audible de depuis les
événements d'aras de dire sans cette
partie là on ne vote pas le texte il
estvident il il est évident que si
demain il y a de nouvell de nouveaux
incidents voir même des attentats dans
ce pays les conditions d'examen de ce
texte seront extrêmement compliquées il
faut se le
dire le gouvernement a voulu mettre une
partie entre guillemets positive sociale
et une partie plus répressive dans le
même texte je pense que ce mélange des
genes rend complle l'adoption ou par la
gauche par la droite de ce texte et si
on part sur un si on part sur un 493 si
on part sur un 493 à l'Assemblée
nationale sur un texte aussi important
je pense que ce sera un échec collectif
et d'abord l'échec du gouvernement et
donc que chacun prenne ses
responsabilité un Mo peut-être un peu
plus léger Patrick caner à l'ancien
ministre des sport même si c'est trist
ça reste léger par rapport à l'actualité
l'élimination de l'équipe de France de
rugby vous l'avez vu ah bah je je je
suis
triste je suis triste en même temps j'ai
vu assisté à un seul match à Lille
euh donc c'était pas un grand match mais
c'était un beau match euh et j'ai cétait
ton garouani hein pour être très clair
j'ai vu 48000 personnes au stade Pierre
monroi à Lille pour un match qui n'était
pas un match de première de premier
niveau beaucoup de femmes beaucoup de
femmes présentes cette fédération de
rugby présidée maintenant par Monsieur
Florent grill doit aller très très loin
ils sont 300000 licenciés c'est rien par
rapport au 2200000 de de foot je dirais
bravo à la France pour avoir organisé
cela je suis triste comme n'importe quel
autre supporter de voir que la France
s'arrête en quart de finale mais il y
aura quand même du monde dans les stades
pour le reste des matchs merci Patrick
han merci d'avoir été avec nous la Une
de La Dépêche
Christelle cible du terrorisme merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous on passe
au club